to present the award for best costume
design are two people who are extremely
fashion minded each heaven set standards
only the very adventurous would dare to
copy one introduced styles way ahead of
her time and the other has pushed the
raincoat industry back 100 years ladies
and gentlemen here is Twiggy and
two-time Oscar nominee Peter Falk
I'm mad about the trendy new designs
they come out with this you're a new
Peter well I don't know it's weaker
that's a hard question for me you know
for me to hand out an award for clothes
I mean I'll get me wrong I'm gonna do it
but I'm not exactly sure I came up with
the right fella yeah
at any rate you look lovely Twiggy so I
guess it's alright for best achievement
and costume design the nominees are
cries and whispers designed by Marek
boss
Ludwick designed by Piero Tosi
the sting designed by Edith Head
Tom Sawyer designed by danke
the way we were designed by Dorothy
Jenkins and moss neighbor
then we have the envelope please oh and
the winner is
eat it head for the stick
just imagine dressing the two handsomest
men in the world and then getting this
that simply couldn't be more happy or
more grateful and thank you all so much